and you would welcome to see you playing
Guerrero da Luz okay from Brazil it
seems he's six what am I playing here
again yeah you want okay yeah to think
about stuff a five really
ok so the rook won't be one they've done
some tactics going on here based on that
rook I have some very direct moves here
like United three and then d for things
like that I'm not quite sure how to play
this here I can I can play many many
central setups this is one of them
before some making it difficult for him
to play to play on 95
I played that badly really badly I
completely missed that he has t5 in this
position now now my rukon be one isn't
isn't good him I mean this is probably
not completely terrible for a wide but
for an opening result with the white
pieces it's pretty pretty bad okay but
this this isn't that bad now where am I
not understanding this position could
very well be the case okay so we'll see
aight here i just straight stuff isn't
the queenside vulnerable that it is
don't think he will take can try that
again I mean he's out waiting me by 100
something points and they have time
disadvantage okay I didn't didn't
consider that move
why didn't I consider it booth okay look
to see one less Roxy to even yeah well I
can go Bishop age six against the smooth
kind of interesting let's see your first
the chicken so he prevents the check
here for the moment ok Bishop h6 still
they cannot take on d3 because of the
the maids on the eighth
I'm also threatening some things on the
side by 25 25 I guess back rank is weak
I mean there is Sir no question about
what price that possible Queen d3 why is
that possible let's let's check your own
not don't want to make a total fool all
on myself then it just doesn't work I
can still take this draw a head Lac
resign I wasn't is click it happened to
me as well now that was a very sudden
end to this to this game and yeah I
think something went wrong there in the
opening I think it's probably a bad idea
to take take 1t four years should play
d3 first and then it's a relatively
normal ish position 95 and I'd be five
or it should be three something like
that I was a little bit unsure how to
handle this year there are a couple of
options hey 5 surprise meal but this
move is very rarely seen and it looks
frankly a little bit weird not weird is
wrong with it looks very weakening and
tongue I don't trust those moves all
that much but I think em it's probably
okay and the immediate capture here I
don't know at least this was a wrong
idea I can't that the engine actually it
doesn't really mind that all that much
and since people yeah maybe it's not
that bad i just felt it just felt a
little bit weird to me queen of three
now is a good move
b7 whoa okay check yeah I went for the
keep it simple approach now we repeat it
over here I had something good what did
I have okay this is the rookie seven I
didn't I was actually willing to repeat
here why not him I'm gaining some points
and I spent too much time here then he
had this move okay and now I think he
should be better and somehow stop me on
the e-file the engine gives this move
that makes an awful lot of center just
block the e-file and also attack this
porn queen be 50 show page six yeah now
you should take on age six and play we
should be six and black is better you
know it has to do something about the
situation yeah I mean you cannot just
play anymore if you play something like
that um I was thinking 3g5 but this is
probably not threatening all that much
however let's say it threatened stuff
but you can go back and here here i mean
i can prove I can play it like those
those kind of moves but they don't work
yeah so this was really yeah giving
giving me the game honor on a silver
plate basically okay tough game against
the high rated opponent thanks for
watching